you said being as as close to Source
Dano this is something that came to me
so many times during my communication
sessions I never experienced this with
the Departed human spirits that I
connected with only the Departed Animal
Spirits they are so close to Source they
are the purest living being to Source I
never got that kind of feeling you said
that pure love thing that you just it
was just enveloped you that for me has
only come through with animals I didn't
find that to be true when Departed
humans came through and that's so
fascinating to me that you experiened
something so similar to that too that it
was just all about that love and that
complete enveloping amazing
Indescribable feeling that it was like
the purest as close as you get to source
as possible so I I totally relate to
that